this is curtin avena reading for
alessandro barbosa
after each of the challenging climactic
boss fights in death's door
you're forced to sit through a brief
eulogy for the foe you've just slain
somber music plays as a gravedigger
arrives to fulfill his duty
summarizing your enemies actions good
and bad while also throwing in a joke or
two for levity
death's door doesn't take itself too
seriously but it always finds
interesting ways to make a point about
the unending cycle of life
and death the pursuit of a means to
unbalance that cycle
and ultimately the consequences of those
actions it's a consistently
entertaining action-adventure game with
an eye-catching art style and engrossing
combat
all which elevates its distinct setting
into something special
[Music]
playing as a fledging of a commission of
crows your duty bound to reclaiming the
souls of those that are meant to pass on
to the next life
aided by doors that can transport you to
lands near and far
you can hop between locals rapidly as
you reap souls
the catch is that every crow needs to
complete its task
in order to halt the flow of their own
life with incomplete missions
forcing you to experience that natural
flow of time
when one such assignment goes poorly and
your target soul is stolen
you'll need to aid an old crow into
opening a large
ominous door to reclaim your lost soul
and in turn
continue to live indefinitely death's
door
starts strong with its introduction to
the commissions with its bleak black and
white presentation fitting in with a
strong noir theme
colors stand out in these bureaucratic
offices with the warm glow of your
weapons and the searing brightness of
sparse neon signs creating a striking
contrast
the rest of death's dora's worlds are
far more colorful but all distinct in
their own ways the dreary
muted colors of the game's opening
cemetery transform
into a lush green forest with a damp and
dark temple
while the snowy white peaks of the
northern mountain regions offer another
opportunity for piercing bright colors
from your attacks
to shine through the isometric angle of
the game's camera doesn't limit your
ability to soak in the artistic beauty
of death's door which consistently
had me stopping to take in the
atmosphere of each new area
enemies are peppered throughout each of
these worlds giving you numerous
opportunities to engage with death doors
simple yet satisfying combat you only
have access to a single weapon at a time
with each one you find
offering its own range combat count
damage and unique ability
your starting sword is great for
whacking out short three-hit combos
while lighter daggers offer less damage
output but a better chance to get more
hits in without needing to take a break
attacks are limited by stamina instead
simply taking a different amount of time
to execute depending on their animation
it can take some time to get used to the
pauses you have to take after each
attack and the lengthier ones after each
combo will punish you for overextending
yourself
however these demands make combat feel
purposeful
each hit you initiate needs to finish
and enemies are designed with this in
mind
they routinely take one more hit to kill
than you might expect encouraging you to
play around with spacing offered by your
dodge
death's door doesn't feel punishing by
any stretch but it's also a game that
plays by a set of rules that don't
always allow you to feel invincible
death's door is a fairly linear
adventure game limiting your movement
through its handful of hubs by
the current abilities you have each new
boss requires a new ability to reach
corresponding with the mechanics you'll
need to overcome
in the eventual fight these abilities
are regularly fun to use too
starting with a simple bow and arrow and
eventually giving away to a fireball
spell
extremely useful bombs and a satisfying
hook shot that can reel you into new
areas and enemies alike each of these
abilities can be upgraded too should you
find each of the associated challenges
out in the world
they're not required but they can
radically alter how you use
each one in combat the hookshot for
example can be upgraded to include a
deadly attack when used against enemies
letting you reel yourself in and fire
off a powerful strike
as soon as you connect these abilities
are mostly used to give you access to
new areas
bombs let you blow up crack walls and
hookshot gives you access to new
platforms
as examples but learning to combine them
into your repertoire of standard attacks
makes combat exhilarating this is
especially true
when you're consistently faced by a
growing roster of enemies
each of which changes the ways in which
you need to engage them
some are incredibly agile such as
hunched over beasts that can jump around
you while throwing boomerangs in your
direction
others are slower but tough to take down
such as armored knights with shields
that take a couple of solid hits to
finally beat
death's store is at its best when it's
throwing you into combat arenas that
pull from the entire roster
challenging you to get hits in where you
can while also keenly identifying which
enemies to take out first
it plays out like a deadly dance of
dexterous dodges and opportunistic
swings of the sword giving skirmishes an
elegant rhythm that's consistently fun
to fight in tune with
each of the hubs that you visit in
death's door is visually distinct and
eye-catching but its layouts are just as
engaging to uncover
as you explore each one is segmented
into small
sections that eventually lead to
shortcuts that loop back around to the
start
acting as ways to quickly get back to
where you were after an untimely death
there's a tangible feeling of relief
each time you open a gate and generate a
ladder that lets you cut out a
challenging section coupled with the
intriguing discovery of how the entire
hub you're in
folds in on itself in a clever way
understanding the layout of each one
lets you tactically plant seeds in
special pots laid around
which offer the only way to regain
health since the seeds for these are
limited and sometimes hard to find
laying out your own root for healing and
identifying which sections you can risk
it blends in well with how hubs have
intricate layouts for you to learn
making your understanding of each root
as crucial as your ability to deal with
the enemies contained within them
although there is a very clear main path
all of death's doors hubs have numerous
secrets for you to uncover
especially during return visits with new
abilities
the standard types are there shrines
that you can pray to to increase your
health and magic for abilities exist
while others are optional boss fights
that will upgrade your abilities
some weapons are also only found outside
of the main path which can drastically
affect your overall playstyle should you
choose to seek them out or not
that's door can be challenging if you
don't take a break from its main path
especially if you find yourself
struggling with the initial health pool
you have without visiting areas or going
out of your way to look for obscure
paths hidden by the game's fixed camera
view
you can quickly find yourself wishing
for the ability to take
one more hit during hard fights it's not
impossible to complete the main story
without this but the adventure certainly
feels tuned towards these small breaks
which can slow down the pacing in an
irritating manner
all these secrets are still present once
credits have rolled
as well as an entirely new one that lets
you explore all the game's hubs at a new
time of day
this opens previously inaccessible areas
and presents new combat challenges for
you to undertake
giving death's door a long tail after
its main narrative is complete
there are areas and doors that cannot be
opened without a thorough comb through
of
areas you might already be familiar with
revealing some hidden depth to each
area that lets you appreciate its design
in a new way it can be frustrating to
have to relearn the structures of some
dungeons again after some time away
and the omission of an in-game map
doesn't let you brush up on these areas
in a quick way
despite that if you've found yourself
enamored with the game's balance of
exploration and combat
the additional content and draw of
uncovering all that
is there as a welcome addition with an
engaging world to explore and
consistently satisfying combat to keep
things entertaining
it's easy to fall in love with dust door
its premise hooks you immediately and it
has the style
and the substance to maintain the
captivating allure of its opening
perhaps
most importantly it's just consistently
fun to play without sharp enemy designs
that keep you on your feet two
challenging boss fights that test your
skills in satisfying ways
there's a lot of death to deal and souls
to reap
but death's door makes it a delight
every step of the way
[Music]
[Music]
you